microcentrifuges differ from standard  laboratory centrifuges in the size of  the tubes used choose a conical tube for  easier extraction of your solution a  lidlock microcentrifuge offers a better  seal to prevent sample loss and  contamination and a screw-top  microcentrifuge tube offers an even  better seal but requires more work since  you gotta you know screw it on and off  versus just popping it on and off choose  a standing freezing centrifuge tube to  store samples at extremely cold  temperatures without needing a rack be  sure not to use these for storage in the  liquid phase of liquid nitrogen unless  they're correctly sealed don't want to  do that our microcentrifuge tubes can  handle 16 000 gs of max force and are  made with high quality polypropylene  they are certified dnase rnas free to  prevent sample contamination